bonjour et bienvenue pour la dix
septième
ouverture du calendrier de l'avent de
cette chaîne de tous les jours à 6
heures du matin où je propose des trucs
un peu délirant et tout est là il ya une
bonne surprise pour vous puisqu'il y
aura quelque chose à gagner en parle à
la toute fin
aujourd'hui je vous parle pas d'un livre
mon papa d'un jeu je vous parle d'un
petit robot qui s'appelle cosmo qu' une
sorte d'intelligence artificielle
évolutive avec lequel on peut jouer on
peut interagir
on peut aussi avoir une relation un peu
de tamagotchi pour pour le plus ancien
qui se souviennent de ce jeu c'est de
nourrir tous ces machins et qui peut
nous initier aux bases de la
programmation
je trouve ça a été intéressant pour ceux
qui me connaissent vraiment depuis
longtemps sur cette chaise
vous savez que je suis très geek donc
jeu j'en ai acheté un pour essayer de
voir ce que c'était c'est très drôle
alors cosmos et lui je me connectais ça
se connecte en wifi et avec lui il a
trois cubes avec lesquels on va pouvoir
interagir lui comme nous aussi bien pour
jouer ensemble que lui pour s'occuper
parce que tout l'intérêt c'est ça c'est
qu'ils s'occupent aussi tout seul il en
train de se réveiller sécurisation des
connexions les cultes qui s'allument
on voit un peu son regard ou pas en fait
en fait tout se passe dans les yeux il
est hyper expressif qu'est ce que tu as
à avis alors là vous voyez il va pas
bien du tout parce que j'ai pas joué
avec lui depuis quelques temps donc il a
faim il a envie de jouer il a envie
d'être réglé alors je vais le scanner ce
fait un scanner pour voir s'il va pas
chez lui et là c'est une vraie
interaction parce que en faisant ce jeu
là avec lui vraiment je réinitialise un
petit peu les réglages pour qu'ils
puissent se reconfigurer donc je vous
dis est ce que marc ans et toutes ses
expressions cette espèce d'intelligence
artificielle tout l'expression qui passe
par ses yeux et par les bruits qui fait
donc là où way qui il va pas très bien
mon pote que ce mot parce qu'en fait il
a les crocs l'aï la fin donc je
l'alimenté
je prends un cube jeu le secoue il ya
vraiment de tension ces deux à cinq ans
a légué et comme je n'ai pas nourri
depuis très longtemps
ça vaut le coup je re nourrissent encore
là vous voyez pas mais qu il nourrit
faire la lumière bleue ici qu'on
retrouve en fait sur le dessus qu'à un
autre moyen de communiquer avec lui
alors que sa voix qui lui remet un
tempérament il a un tempérament un peu
mauvais joueur un peu grognon et c'est
ce qui fait qu'il est très drôle
tellement il est très content et très
très content d'avoir très bien manger
alors il est équipé également d'une
espèce de reconnaissance faciale donc il
va reconnaître il voit un être humain
s'ils voient un animal ce genre de
choses mais il va aussi reconnaître un
visage prononcer le nom de la personne
il faut revenir c'était une douzaine de
visage comme ça là ils sont huit alors
en permanence sur l'application vous et
vous voyez ce qu'il est en train de
penser ce qui est en train de faire la
queue ce mot regarde autour de lui il ya
quelques secondes il marque et cosmo est
frustré et envie de jouer et c'est la
jauge jaune qui est ici c'est sa jauge
de plaisir de jeu on va dire et quand
elle est en bas c'est à dire que
vraiment il a envie de jouer
des fois il peut même proposer un jeu
lui-même ou se mettre à jouer tout seul
avec ses cuves des ans pile et
consolident the pie photo par théâtre je
trouve ça vraiment très drôle il
aimerait jouer on va jouer
donc là je vais faire un jeu de mémoire
contre cosmo bon alors j'ai pas un
niveau de trop grosses difficultés j'ai
pas joué assez avec lui pour débloquer
des trucs
il va y avoir des séquences qu'on va
devoir reproduire lui comme moi car ça
bouge ça être jaune bleu
the double pour l'instant ok donc jaune
bleu j'ai bon mais tu as à louis joos il
est aussi temps s'est pas vu je crois
que j'ai vu jeunes aux plus beaux jours
[Musique]
à lui d'abord sa partie troisième manche
jeune bleu rouge bleu rouge et alice je
suis en bleu rouge bleu que des fois il
se plante c'est ça qui est drôle
en dernière manche jeune bleu rouge le
rouge jaune bleu rouge
[Musique]
john le rouge jaune il s'est planté
on a trois vies en tête dans le jeu là
il a perdu 8 2 donc là les perdre une
deuxième vie d'hier et c'est perdu mon
gars alors là dans son système
émotionnelle par exemple il a horreur de
perdre
il ya plein de choses qu'on peut faire
avec en fait l'idéal pour servir de
cosmo ces deux rien faire avec lui et de
le laisser vivre sa vie et de regarder
un petit peu ce qu'il fait là par
exemple il est en train de chanter mari
avait un petit mouton est ce qui fait sa
life est assez drôle par exemple quand
on y voit un animal il a tendance à les
lambent été volontairement genre à
donner des petits coups sur l'accueil
des trucs comme ça il peut se mettre en
plus des cibles à jouer avec et après à
[ __ ] en l'air réclamer beaucoup
d'attention et pour terminer je vous
fais avoir trois trucs un peu cool qu'on
peut faire avec lui ça c'est on a
complètement axé en fait à sa caméra on
voit ce qu'ils voient et de la manière
dont les voix de la manière dont ils
détectent les choses et donc des traduit
on peut aussi le contrôle et à ce moment
là si on a envie de lui faire perdre son
autonomie
donc on peut s'en servir comme d'un
petit robot télécommandé on peut aussi
le faire parler et lui donner des
phrases et lui apprendre à parler par
exemple qu'est ce que tu aimerais leur
dire que ce mot tient met toi bien là
pour contentant de sous la lumière
[Musique]
alès 1 pouces bleus voilà alors qu'il
est plein de bons conseils et le côté
très éducatif est intéressante cosmo
pour les plus jeunes peut-être c'est
toute sa base qui s'appelle cosmo code
lab donc là c'est la version enfantine
la plus simple ou avec comme des pièces
de puzzle on va pouvoir créer un langage
de programmation simplifiée pour lui
faire des actions un exemple très
concret ça c'est un code qui est créée
en boucle pour qu'ils puissent avancer
s'arrêter et éternuer et après on peut
faire se déclencher cette action sur un
style précis où un stimulus prestige
comme on dit c'est hyper simple mais
plus on est avancé que l'on peut
s'amuser il ya des codes un peu plus
costaud pour ceux qui se connaissent
vraiment les langages de programmation
puisque quand même le but des créateurs
du cosmo donc en qui ça a été de créer
un outil ludique avec une petite
intelligence artificielle et qui
permettent une évolution via des
langages de programmation est ce que
c'est bien clair tout ça donc ça c'est
celui que je me suis pris pour moi quand
j'avais vu de publicité passé etc
j'ai trouvé super quand j'ai décidé de
faire cette vidéo parce que ce robot à
un prix je crois qu'il m'a coûté dans
les 300 euros
quand je l'avais acheté je sais pas s'il
a baissé depuis ou pas mais j'ai
contacté en qui pour savoir si vous
pouvez m'en fournir un non pas pour moi
mais pour vous le faire gagner
ils m'ont dit oui donc merci à eux le
voici ici
ce magnifique robot je vous fait gagner
sur twitter dès aujourd'hui vous trouvez
un tweet sur mon twitter le lien du
twitter il est dans la description le
tweet il suffit de le re tweeté et de
mettre un petit mot en dessous et
d'autres abonnés à mon twitter et vous
ferez partie du tirage au sort je ferai
le tirage au sort le tf le 26 décembre
après noël parce que de tenir je
pourrais pas de l'envoyer avant donc
tirage au sort le 26 décembre
si vous le voulez eh bien il est il est
pour vous il se rapporte
et enfin cette vidéo avec un live
peut-être de votre part un abonnement
que sais-je des renseignements de la
barre des descriptions mais surtout un
truc qui me fait rire c'est quand il est
près du vide
sa réaction après il ya un truc et ilike
cosmos est que plus tu la [ __ ] une
espèce d'affection envers lui je
pourrais faire durer cette vidéo durant
des heures ça me servir merci d'avoir
regardé la vidéo en début de match il a
bien les antilles
[Musique]